if there's one thing that we need to do
to create more jobs it will only come
from engagement so what we need to do is
to put policymakers educators the
companies and the youth who are
unemployed you know like a
representation of that all into one
dialogue where they come up with that
solution because if the corporation's
keep on trying to come up with solution
on their own ah it won't be very
relevant and if the educators keep on
trying to do that on their own again it
won't be very relevant if policymakers
do the same it won't be relevant so you
need to create a complete platform that
brings in all the players into one
constructive dialogue of finding a
solution and and this solution wouldn't
be cautious or training or spoon feeding
kind of stuff it should be more about
how do you help these people create jobs
for themselves so more about
entrepreneurship and self-employment